we obviously aren't much uh more
vociferous Defenders of the police
because the the Civil Authority is a
good thing and we need law and we need
order and these are all necessary to a
flourishing and just and virtuous
society that doesn't mean that we don't
recognize that this is a fallen world
and bad things happen and we can make
improvements and sometimes policies have
unintended consequences and sometimes
there are bad people that need to be
dealt with of course not and and if
people are are so reductive in their
politics that they just uh make every
issue merely partisan and knee-jerk well
then then we're not going to get very
far in politics at all